FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you for
coming to our most recent NASA
at Google Talk.
We are pleased to welcome
Steve Hipskind today.
Is that right?
Pronouncing it correctly?
Steve is the chief of the Earth
Science Division at NASA Ames.
He has been at NASA
Ames for 35 years
and is retiring in three days.
So we caught him
right before he left.
He's going on a 9-day
backpacking trip
to celebrate his 35 years.
Steve has done a whole slew
of exploration in the Arctic,
and the subarctic, and
many places in between.
And we're really pleased
to have him today.
So please help me welcome Steve.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE HIPSKIND: Well,
thank you very much.
Thank you for coming.
I'd like to thank Terry
Fong for suggesting
this and Mary for inviting me.
It's always a lot of fun to come
and talk about your passion,
so appreciate you guys
coming here today.
I am going to talk about
NASA's Earth science program.
So I'm guessing people here kind
of know what that's all about.
But a lot of times, people
have no clue that NASA actually
studies the Earth.
But before I get
into that, I wanted
to give a little shoutout to our
friends in planetary science.
We had one of the
co-investigators
on the New Horizons
mission which
just did the flyby of the dwarf
planet Pluto, but very exciting
event.
We had a lot of
people over at Ames
that we're watching kind
of the real-time feed.
And actually, Dr. Cruikshank,
who is our co-investigator,
was actually at the
Applied Physics Lab
at Johns Hopkins for
the fun and excitement.
So this mission was selected
to go ahead in 2001.
It actually launched in 2006.
So it took nine years
to get to Pluto.
That's 3 billion miles.
So if you figure that out, it's
about 40,000 miles an hour.
So this is a picture of
approaching the dwarf planet
at about a million
kilometers out.
So the other interesting thing
about the New Horizons mission
is it was-- because
it had to go so far,
it was intended to be a
pretty simple mission.
Its instruments were
not articulated,
so you had to move the
spacecraft to view the planet.
But that meant that you
couldn't view the planet
and do communications because
you had to turn the spacecraft
to do communication.
So as they were
doing the flyby, they
turned communications
off so that they could
do all of the observations.
But the bandwidth to get that
data 3 billion miles from that
far away in the solar system
is 2 kilobits a second.
So it's taking a while
to get all of the data
that they took on the mission.
So again, this is
from a-- I'm sorry,
this was from about 100
million kilometers out.
This was at about 50
million kilometers.
And then as they got
a little bit closer,
they started seeing
what they thought
was a heart-shaped
feature on the planet.
But the closest approach-- this
is released for the first time
ever-- they found Pluto.
So it's pretty exciting stuff.
OK, what I'm going to talk about
is really NASA's Earth science
program.
So I don't know.
Does everybody
recognize this image,
know what year this
image was taken?
Any ideas?
1968.
So it was actually the
first mission to the moon
where they actually just
went around the moon
and didn't land on the moon.
So this was actually-- I think
it was Christmas Eve in 1968.
But this really
demonstrated the power
of using the space observation
perspective to look back
at our home planet.
I mean, this was at a time where
environmental issues were just
coming to the fore.
It was when the Environmental
Protection Agency was created,
the Environmental Protection
Act, so pretty exciting stuff.
But a lot of people-- if
you follow politics at all,
you recognize that
there are certain people
in the country that
don't think NASA
should be doing Earth science.
And to them, we can look at
the authorizing legislation
of NASA, which actually, if you
look at what that authorizing
legislation asks us to
do, the first priority is
the expansion of human
knowledge of the Earth
and phenomena in the atmosphere.
So clearly it's in our charter.
But it's actually only been
since the human spaceflight
program that we've really
focused on a program
to look at the Earth from space.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-T minus 10--
STEVE HIPSKIND: And so--
-9, 8, 7--
STEVE HIPSKIND:
Yeah, that's funny.
It's not showing up
the same way on my-- so
this is a little
picture of what we do.
-0, and ignition.
And liftoff of the Atlas V
rocket on the Landsat Data
Continuity mission,
continuing the 40-year legacy
of preserving Earth's
natural resources from space.
STEVE HIPSKIND: So
probably a lot of you
have heard about Landsat.
It's really the oldest
Earth observing program
that we have at NASA.
It started in the early 1970s.
And so it's been almost
a continuous 40 year
record of Earth observation.
And for the kind
of stuff that we're
trying to do on the Earth,
the time series aspect
of these observations
is absolutely
critical to really
understanding what's
going on on our home planet.
[END PLAYBACK]
STEVE HIPSKIND:
So this next video
is just a time lapse, again
through the Landsat program,
of changes to this
particular urban area.
Does everybody recognize
where that urban area is?
Shout it out.
Come on now.
AUDIENCE: Las Vegas?
STEVE HIPSKIND: Las Vegas.
So actually, this is showing
a full 40-year history
of the development of Las Vegas.
And if you watch
this closely, you
can see that it basically
went from a very small,
confined area around
the strip to now
really building
out into the desert
there to the left
of the downtown
and to the left of the image.
So again, it's really
that time continuity
of these observations
that really gives us
the ability to look at what's
going on on the planet.
And so some of
the things that we
can do with this
perspective from space
is we can look at the biological
productivity on the earth.
This is the SeaWiFS mission.
But this basically shows-- this
is a six year sequence showing
the seasonal greening
of the planet
and then the receding
in the winter months.
But again, just a simple
time series of that image
shows very quickly
a global snapshot
of what's going on
with the biosphere.
So what is NASA's ambition?
It's a pretty modest ambition
to try to understand and model
the whole planet.
And so this was
actually a diagram.
It's actually a
famous diagram called
the Bretherton diagram
that was actually
created in the late 1980s.
But it basically
tried to pictorialize
all of the different
subsystems on the Earth,
and the interconnected
nature of the subsystems,
and the challenge of
trying to understand
the nature of those systems,
but also the interconnections
of those systems, so
systems of systems.
And you'll notice there
on the right-hand side
is the human activities.
That's not something
that we have focused
on very much in the history
of the Earth Science program,
but it's something
that we're beginning
to really put more focus on.
And I'll get back
to that in a minute.
So what do we do to
try to understand
all of these subsystems?
This is the current
constellation
of NASA satellites.
And so we have
this constellation.
There are currently
somewhere between 18 and 20
Earth-observing
satellites from NASA
that are currently up there.
And then the color-coding shows
the existing constellation,
then the missions that
are in development
and planned for future launch.
But it's a fairly
complex endeavor.
People typically
don't think of NASA
when they think about
doing Earth science,
but we actually have the
largest Earth science
program on the planet.
And it's largely because
it's fairly expensive
to do these kinds of
space-based missions.
So this next image
is just an image
of what these satellites
look like in space.
And so typically for
Earth observation,
we have what are called
Sun-synchronous polar orbits,
which means the
satellites are crossing
the same place on the
Earth at the same time,
but they're doing
it in polar orbit
so that as the Earth
rotates, we eventually
image the entire planet.
And so this, again,
is a sequence
of those constellations.
One thing you'll notice is
there's a bunch of them.
I'll show this in a second.
But there are a bunch of them
that, for the first time,
we've been attempting
to fly several
of the satellites
in close formation.
And basically, that
just leverages the power
of getting these co-located
in time observations, which
makes it much easier to
do some of the analysis.
In the last, oh,
year and a half,
we've launched a number
of new satellites--
the Global Precipitation
mission, which
is-- one of the things
that I didn't say
is that the work that we do
is very heavily interagency.
So there are a lot
of agencies in the US
that have a piece
of Earth science.
Typically, other
agencies have kind
of operational responsibility.
NOAA does weather forecasting.
USGS does earthquake
observation and response.
And indeed, a lot of what we do
is we actually build and launch
the satellites.
So we build and
launch the satellites
for NOAA, for the
weather satellites.
We also-- Landsat
is fundamentally
a US Geological Survey mission.
But we build and launch
that satellite as well.
The Global
Precipitation Mission is
an example of the international
flavor of what we do.
And so the Japanese
actually built the radar
on the GPM mission.
But if you think about it,
2/3 of the planet is ocean.
And so other than having these
space-based observations,
there's no way to get
precipitation measurements
over the ocean over a
big part of the planet.
So it's only been since we've
been doing these observations
from space that we have
a critical component
of the weather
system on the planet,
but also how the climate system
is changing, how precipitation
around the planet is changing.
SMAP is one of the most recent
missions that we've launched.
It's the soil
moisture measurement
using an L-band radar
tuned to humidity
in the top several
centimeters of soil.
But again, for
the first time, we
have a global picture of what
the soil moisture looks like,
which is hugely important for,
for example, agricultural water
demand and things like that.
Unfortunately, SMAP has only
been up for several months.
And it has two instruments--
a radar and a radiometer.
They're having problems
with the radar right now.
We've gotten some
global data sets.
But right now, the
instrument is being
debugged to try to figure out
what's going on with the radar.
We still have the radiometer,
which also provides a soil
moisture but not with the same
level of spatial resolution
as the radar instrument.
I mentioned the
constellation-- we
refer to it as the A-Train--
which is largely making
atmospheric measurements.
And so again, these
satellites are
flying within a
minute of each other
in terms of when they actually
cross a particular place
on the Earth.
And so I mentioned
one of our challenges
really is to better understand
the impact of human activity.
And if you read the little
blurb in the introduction
to the talk, I want to show you
some of the measurements that
are really truly the
measurements from space that
are really most uniquely showing
human presence on the planet.
And that's the nighttime images.
So you've seen a lot of
the night lights images.
They have a lot
of global images.
This actually is
an image that was
taken from the
International Space Station
by one of the astronauts--
actually, Don Pettit, who
actually is from Oregon state.
But he actually figured out
how to take their cameras-- he
actually took a Makita drill
and created his own motion
compensation, because of course,
the space station is traveling
at thousands of miles an hour.
And so trying to take
a picture of the Earth
is a little bit challenging.
They actually have
much faster cameras.
This was done probably
close to 10 years ago now.
But the really
neat thing that you
can see from night lights
images, particularly these ones
from the space station which
are much higher resolution
than the other satellites where
you've seen night light images,
you can really start to see not
just the presence of humans,
but you can see different
aspects of human activity.
For example, you can easily pick
out transportation corridors.
You can pick out
industrial sections.
Cities-- you can see
San Francisco there
at the top end of the Bay
is very brightly colored.
And so one of the
things that you can do
is begin to use this as a
surrogate for where the carbon
emissions are.
That's not so much of a
problem in the United States
because we have a lot of other
information that tells us that.
But around the rest of
the world and particularly
the developed
countries that don't
have that kind of
data-taking capability,
it's a really nice way to
pinpoint where the carbon
emissions are coming from
in terms of writing carbon
treaties and things like that.
The other fantastic
thing about night lights
which I find really
intriguing is the extent
to which you can see the impacts
of human decision-making.
And so we all very much
benefit in the Bay Area
from decisions that were
made in the '50s and '60s
where people set aside
open space in the Bay Area.
So what you see
there, of course,
is Silicon Valley, San Francisco
at the top end of the Bay,
San Jose at the bottom end.
But what you don't see
is where the mountains
are, because we've
kept development out
of the hills for the most part.
And so you can see that very
clearly in an image like this.
It's even actually more
striking in this image,
which is of Washington DC.
And for those of you know
that know Washington DC,
you know that it was
developed as a 10 mile
on a side square turned on
its side so it's a diamond.
But the remarkable thing to
me, the very bright lights
are kind of the central
DC, the mall area.
But you can see the outline
of that 10 mile square
in this image with
nothing other than lights.
And so basically
what that says is
that people are making
decisions in one neighborhood
about nighttime
lighting that are
very different from the
community next door.
So it's a very powerful tool
for looking at human presence,
changing human
presence, and impacts
of human policy management
decisions on the Earth--
pretty exciting stuff.
Right now, the regular
satellite images
are much lower resolution
than these images.
We at NASA Ames have
really pushed hard
to get NASA to think about
putting up a night light
imager that would give you
this kind of resolution,
and you could really do
some interesting things.
I'm going to talk
a little bit more
about public/private
partnerships in a little bit.
But I think this is one
where if we don't do it
in the government, I'm
hopeful that others will find
this interesting and valuable
enough to actually look
at doing.
So one of the other things
that we do at NASA--
and because we can't see all
of the detailed geophysical
phenomenon from space just
because we're so far away--
and it is interesting how
it's changing all the time
in terms of our capabilities.
But one of the other tools
that we have in the tool set
is aircraft.
And so NASA has
historically had aircraft
that focus on high
altitude measurements.
So that aircraft in the
upper left, for example,
is really a converted
U-2 spy plane
that we've converted to do
geophysical measurements.
We've had that since
the early '70s.
We actually started the NASA
Airborne Program at NASA Ames
back in the '70s.
You notice that we
paint ours white
because we're the good guys.
But more recently,
we've been starting
to use the NASA
Global Hawk, which
is the aircraft on the
upper right, which is kind
of a replacement for the U-2.
It flies roughly the
same altitude, roughly
the same payload capability.
But it really allows us to
get to places on the planet,
particularly in the
upper atmosphere, that we
just-- there's no
other way to get
to those kinds of measurements.
And so again, even though
people don't really
think of Earth science
when they think of NASA,
we actually have the
largest airborne program
of any agency on
the planet as well.
The DC-8 in the
lower left is just
an old commercial airliner,
but we've pretty much
stripped it completely bare
so that we can actually
put laboratory-size
instruments in that aircraft.
And we have a really nice
program every summer.
It's actually called the Student
Airborne Research Program.
So if any students out
there in the audience
are interested in
doing this, we actually
bring in about 30 students
from around the country.
We actually put instruments
on the aircraft.
That's a picture of some of
the students on the aircraft.
They take the data.
They develop their
own research project.
And then they actually
take the data,
do their research and
analysis, and then
present it at the
end of the summer.
It's a really exciting program,
really hands-on opportunity
to do Earth science.
And so one of the prime examples
of how the airborne program
really plays is
that in the 1980s,
there was the ozone hole,
and nobody really knew
what was going on with that.
NASA actually had just launched
the Total Ozone Mapping
Spectrometer, or TOMS.
And so we could see those
images of the globe looking down
on the South Pole.
We could see the ozone
hole, but we couldn't
determine what was causing it.
So there were several
theories at the time.
Nitric oxide is
released by aircraft.
And there was a concern
that there was just
a climatological shift in
the circulation patterns.
But one of the top
contenders was CFC,
is the chlorofluorocarbons
and whether those were really
causing the ozone hole.
It wasn't until we were able
to take our high altitude
aircraft, which was really
the only way in the world
to get these measurements,
and we actually went down
based out of Punta Arenas, which
is on the Strait of Magellan
at the southern tip
of South America.
And we are able to make
measurements directly
into the ozone hole which was in
the stratosphere over the South
Pole.
And we were able to bring
back what we've always
referred to as the smoking gun.
It showed that there was
this tremendous correlation
with the chlorine
molecules that we
were seeing, which ended up
being the source of the ozone
hole.
And the exciting thing
about that for us
is that that data that
we took fed directly
into international policy,
which became the Montreal
Protocol which basically
calls all the developed
countries to phase out
the development of CFCs.
And we averted losing
our stratospheric ozone
layer, which protects us.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-NASA scientists
are joining with--
STEVE HIPSKIND: This is
just a quick video clip
of some of the other
more recent work
that we've done with the
Global Hawk aircraft.
But essentially, we put
instruments on that aircraft.
And in this case, we were
very interested in what's
the impact of climate
change on the water
cycle, and particularly,
how does water vapor
go from the lowest
part of the atmosphere
into the stratosphere?
Because if you get more
water in the stratosphere,
it actually has a huge
impact on the ozone cycle
and potentially leads to
more ozone production.
And so we actually-- again,
this was really the only way
to get that data in
the upper atmosphere
over the middle of the Pacific.
The Global Hawk gives us
a new measurement domain
because it can stay up in
the air for 31 hours compared
to the U-2, which can stay up
for only about eight hours.
[END PLAYBACK]
STEVE HIPSKIND: And
so we're actually
able to go get
those measurements.
And indeed in this project
that we got funded here
at NASA Ames, we actually
showed that there's much more
water vapor getting
into the stratosphere
than people had anticipated.
So again, our stuff
is not quite as sexy
as doing a flyby of the planets,
but it's really the stuff
that NASA does that's most
directly impactful to life
here on Earth.
Another thing that we've
done with aircraft,
this is actually a satellite
image of the big wildfires
in Southern California.
This was actually in 2007.
But again, the
satellite gives you
kind of the overall picture.
But in terms of decision
making for the firefighters,
it's not nearly enough detail.
And so we embarked
on this program
where we put a very high
dynamic-range infrared
sensor on the Ikhana UAV
and really changed the way
that the US fights fires.
We actually worked with
folks in Terry's organization
and intelligent
systems and took some
of the autonomy and intelligent
planning and scheduling,
and repurposed actually software
that was developed for the Mars
rovers, and repurposed that for
managing the data coming down
from the UAV.
Put together a satellite
link, on-board processing
on the aircraft so that
we were able to generate--
So the image on the left
there is what the firefighter
sees on the ground.
It's very hard to see kind
of where the fire fronts are,
where it is relative
to the terrain.
And so with the
infrared sensor, we're
able look through
the smoke, determine
where the hot spots are or
where the fire fronts are.
And then we actually
use Google Earth
because that was
very standardized
in the firefighting
community, and we're
able to show them
where these fire
fronts were and were moving.
And so they, for
the first time ever,
used real-time data that we
were giving them from NASA.
And they were using that to make
decisions about putting boots
on the ground.
Typically, they had done
infrared imagery before,
but they would go up in an
aircraft, take the data.
Aircraft would land.
There would be a group that
would process the data.
And maybe six hours later, the
firefighters got those images.
Well, a lot happens in
six hours in a big fire.
So we were giving
them real-time images.
And indeed, we were
doing basically
a web-based distribution so
our data was going directly
onto the incident command center
set up for the big wildfires.
And that was going
up on their boards
within five minutes
of taking the data.
And so NASA doesn't fight fires.
And so one of our
challenges is kind
of the research operations.
How do we transfer
this technology
into the hands of
the agency who has
the responsibility-- in
this case, the US Forest
Service-- for fighting fires?
And so they've
actually adopted what
we referred to as a
Collaborative Decision
Environment, the software.
And that now they use that at
NIFC, the National Interagency
Fire Center, in Boise.
And they actually use that
software to manage wildfires
across the United States.
We also gave them,
on permanent loan,
the infrared sensor
so they actually
can duplicate the capabilities
that we demonstrated.
We're more recently looking at
using smaller robotic aircraft.
The images in the left there
are of our Sierra aircraft,
which we went from not
ever using this for science
to going to Svalbard, which
is the island owned by
and north of Norway, so
above the Arctic Circle.
So we kind of went from testing
this thing out here at Ames
to going to one of the
most extreme environments
on the planet.
But we demonstrated
that you can fly
these aircraft for about 10
hours and return useful data.
In this case, we were looking
at the surface roughness
of the Arctic ice sheets
to look at can you
determine the age of the
ice from remote sensing
and improve your remote
sensing algorithms from space.
The image in the
lower right there
is actually some much
smaller aircraft-- actually,
Dragon Eyes.
And we were able to
work with, actually
in this case, NASA JPL that
had a very small SO2 sensor.
And we were able to fly
these-- this is actually
Mount Turrialba in Costa Rica.
And so we were actually
able to demonstrate
that we could fly
these aircraft actually
at much higher than they had
originally been intended to fly
and we could look at sulfur
dioxide emissions coming out
of the volcanoes.
And so our next step
actually this summer
is to fly these
aircraft in formation,
and so rather than having
to talk individually
to the aircraft, talk
to them as a group,
and be able to do broader
spatial measurements
with these small platforms.
And then another-- so
this is a little bit
of the public/private
partnership.
I don't know how
many of you know
that your principals
actually have
a bunch of private aircraft
that they keep over
at Moffett Field.
And one of the quid pro quos of
this public/private partnership
is they've allowed us to put
our scientific instruments
on this aircraft that they own.
It's called an Alpha Jet.
And so we've developed
a greenhouse gas
payload that we put on there
to measure CO2, methane, ozone,
water vapor, et cetera.
And the image in
the middle there,
one of the things that we do
with satellite observations
that the aircraft program
is very helpful for
is doing validation of
the satellite images.
So we look at places
on the planet.
This is Railroad
Valley, which is
a very high, very uniform playa
in the high desert in Nevada.
But with this partnership,
we can actually
make very routine measurements
that we wouldn't otherwise
be able to make if
we had to propose
to use the NASA aircraft,
which are in very high demand.
So we've been making
these measurements
over Railroad Valley every
month for the last five years.
So it's a very powerful tool.
And this is just a little image.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
STEVE HIPSKIND: We were working
with the Japanese who also
are measuring CO2 from space.
So this is a Japanese
team that were actually
in Railroad Valley
making measurements
of CO2 and methane.
So we're able to fly the Alpha
Jet from here at Moffett Field
and fly right over that playa.
And then we have them circle
up and do a vertical profile
to compare to the
satellite measurements.
So it's a really
exciting capability.
It's actually kind
of fun because we
try to get the profiles as
close to the surface as we can.
-[INAUDIBLE].
STEVE HIPSKIND: This is
probably a little bit closer
than we expected them to do.
But you can't say we're
not close to the surface
with those measurements.
[END PLAYBACK]
And so what do we do with
all of this information?
The whole idea is to try to
not only understand, but to be
able to predict what's going
to happen in the future.
This is a really
nice, colorful image
of some modeling work
that's actually done
at NASA Goddard in Maryland.
But it's looking at
the atmospheric aerosol
and it's color coded
by aerosol source,
but very high resolution
meteorological analyses
showing how aerosols, for
example, from Saharan Africa
get transported
across the Atlantic.
So again, this is the ultimate
goal of that Bretherton
diagram, is to put all
of this information
together and be able to
predict into the future.
One of the things that
we're doing at NASA Ames
is what we call the
NASA Earth Exchange.
It's actually very
similar to-- and we've
had some collaborative
relationships
with the Google Earth
Engine folks here at Google.
But we can use that
to really assimilate
all of these very
large satellite data
sets into a single
place and then have
the data co-located with
the various analytics
and large models.
In this particular
case, we're using
it to look at irrigation
demand in the Central
Valley of the US.
We had done a lot of
work up at Napa Valley,
doing that for grapes.
So we had the opportunity a
few years ago to scale this up.
And now, we're looking at
the whole Central Valley.
But we're showing
that you can actually
reduce the amount
of irrigated water
to kind of an optimum
level, still maintain
the same level of
agricultural productivity,
but fairly significantly
reduce the water.
In some side-by-side tests
in the Salinas Valley,
we were able to demonstrate that
you could maintain productivity
with up to 35%
reduction in water.
You're not going to get that
across the whole Central
Valley, but even if
you could save 5% to 7%
of the water usage in
California, that would be huge.
Another thing that we've been
able to do with the NASA Earth
Exchange is climate downscaling.
We've actually recently scaled
this up to the whole planet.
But this is taking the IPCC,
the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change, and kind
of the best models that
come out of that group.
I thought that was
set up to repeat,
but let me see if I
can show that again.
This is basically just showing
from current to 2100 what
the state of the art model show
for temperature in the United
States, which actually,
if you look at this,
it's pretty scary.
Because you can see that
the whole central part
of the United States
actually looks
a lot like the southwestern
United States by 2100.
That's using the scenario of
not a lot of carbon reduction.
But it's really
kind of the scenario
that we're currently on.
So it's actually a pretty
accurate portrayal.
One other example I'll
show really quickly-- this
is some recent work mapping
fallowed fields in California,
again, just using remote sensing
but using fairly sophisticated
analysis tools to get to what's
a fallow field versus just
roadway or whatever.
And so we're
producing these maps.
This is from 2011 to 2015.
But you can track the increasing
amount of fallowed fields
in the Central Valley,
which is basically
a direct impact of the drought
on California agriculture.
And so this work has been used
by the California Department
of Water Resources to brief the
governor's drought task force.
It actually just
came out last week
in a White House missive on
what is the US government doing
to address climate change.
So this data was
featured in that as well.
So I'm going to quickly shift
gears and talk about some
of the interesting stuff that
we're doing at Ames in looking
at, again, remote sensing.
This is what we end up
calling fluid lensing.
But in my humble
opinion, I actually
think this has the possibility
of completely revolutionizing
the way we do remote sensing.
And so what you're
seeing here is an image
of the Venus transit
of the Sun that
happened several years ago.
And so this is an
image of the Sun.
Of course, the black spot is
the Venus transit of the Sun.
But the remarkable
thing is we were
able to get this kind of detail
on the surface of the Sun.
And you would think
that that might
be a satellite circulating
around the sun,
but this is actually
the telescope
that those images
were taken from.
And so normally when you
have a piece of glass,
that gives you the
diffraction limit.
It limits your spatial
resolution that you can see.
But what this young researcher
Ved Chirayath is doing
is actually using atmospheric
turbulence as a lens.
And so it basically gets
around the limitation
of having to put big giant
pieces of glass in space
and allows you to
use the atmosphere
to lens those images.
And so I actually got him to
do some work in Earth science.
And so I asked him if he
could take that same technique
and look downward,
and what could you do.
And so he actually recognized
that one really interesting
thing that you could do
is imaging shallow water
ecosystems.
And so this is actually an
image at the Stanford pool.
That's Ved on the
right looking up.
And so he's got a little logo
that's hung above the pool.
And you can see
that's what it would
look like if you're sitting
on the bottom of the pool.
But if you apply the fluid
lensing-- so basically
in this case, you're using
that air/water interface
in the waves.
And you can imagine that
when the wave goes by,
it actually acts as a lens and
it both magnifies and sharpens
the image.
And so you can go from that
image in the upper left
to that image in the lower left.
So you can see that it
actually is slightly
magnified from the real image,
but it also basically gives you
an accurate portrayal
of what's really there.
And so he's taken this.
He's actually put it on
a small quadcopter UAV.
And he's imaged two places now.
One was the coral reefs
in American Samoa.
And this is actually in
Shark Bay in Australia
where there are these
stromatolite pools.
Stromatolites are the oldest
living organisms on the planet.
They're responsible for creating
the oxygen in the atmosphere.
And this is the
first time anyone's
ever gotten permission
to actually do
flying over a remote
sensing of Hamelin Pool.
But this is what you would
see from that imagery
if you're just flying along.
And this is applying the
fluid lensing technique.
So he's actually
generated literally
centimeter scale,
three-dimensional images
of both these stromatolites
as well as the coral reefs.
And it gives you this
incredibly powerful capability,
for the first time, to
use a remote sensing
to do things like
identify species
differentiation in coral reefs.
And so you can look at
impacts of changing climate
on specific species
in the coral reefs.
So I'll finish by
just saying that we
as humans on this planet
face tremendous issues
environmentally.
And it really takes much
more than the US government
or all the governments.
It takes all of us
working on these problems.
And so I really
personally feel that
public/private partnerships are
an important way going forward
in that it's really
a way to leverage
the financial resources
that companies like Google
and others can
bring to the table
and looking at
different ways to get
these measurements or different
ways to analyze that data.
This actually looks
like a cartoon picture.
This is actually the
launch of some CubeSats
from the International
Space Station.
That one in the
center is actually
what was referred to as
PhoneSat at the time.
But it's the same
guys that were working
at Ames that went off and
created Planet Labs up
in San Francisco.
But I think it's really
important for private sector
companies, like Skybox,
like Planet Labs,
to really push the
federal government.
Because we're not the most
fast-paced nimble organization
on the planet, but there's
sort of this balance.
Because it's important to have
the sort of the long-term view,
which the US government
has, combined with sort
of new capabilities, new ideas.
And I think that's
the way that we're
going to move forward and
solve some of these problems
that we face.
So thank you very much.
Appreciate being here.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Fluid lens must
be highly irregular, yeah?
STEVE HIPSKIND:
Highly irregular?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean,
it's not a nice, smooth lens
like a lens in my telescope.
STEVE HIPSKIND: Oh, absolutely.
So I mean, there's a tremendous
amount of compute power
that-- I mean, so
those original images
were created with a GoPro,
which is pretty remarkable when
you see what he was
able to retrieve.
But he's actually
gotten some funding
from the Earth Science
Technology office, which
is our technology
development at NASA,
to build much more
sophisticated cameras which also
have incredibly
powerful CPUs on them
to do the image processing.
It's essentially machine
vision because you
have to look at the
scale of the turbulence,
and then you have
to figure that out.
And then you have to be able
to stitch all that together.
So it's a pretty
challenging problem.
But we've actually just put in
a proposal to put those cameras,
which are kind of
state-of-the-art video cameras.
I think they are 4K
by 4K imagers that are
doing like 90 images a second.
So it's a tremendous
amount of data
that's being generated,
a tremendous problem
to solve in terms of
just processing the data.
But we're hoping that that
proposal will be successful
and we'll launch these
things into space
and test what he's
done on a quadcopter
from space, see what we can get.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE HIPSKIND: So
the dome actually
covers a large
steerable antenna.
And so of course, we're
dependent on satellite
communication to
use that aircraft
because we're typically sending
it from Southern California.
We can send it all the way
to Australian and back.
So we need a way to communicate
with the aircraft in flight.
So yeah, so there's a
big rotating dish that
sits under that big dome.
Unfortunately for us, it
takes a lot of payload space,
so we complain about that.
We'd like them to
shrink the dish.
But if any of you
guys have any ideas--
And one of the challenges
that we face in Earth science
is there's so many
things that we
need to understand that
it's hard to sort of pick--
in fact, we as a community
have a hard time prioritizing
where we should put
our resources because
of that reason.
In fact, one of the
things that NASA does
is it seeks input
from the community
through the National
Research Council.
And we actually--
every 10 years, we
generate what's called
a Decadal Survey.
And so we actually ask know the
smartest people in the country
to give us those priorities.
I think more and
more, one thing that's
becoming more and
more important is
spatial resolution and
the ability to see things
at much finer detail.
Because we're
getting to the point
where our models can
actually give us--
we're getting projections down
to regional and local scales,
but we need the data sets to
corroborate the model results.
And so clearly, spatial
resolution is a big one.
Just coming up with new
kinds of measurements.
I didn't show it, but the
results from the soil moisture
measurement-- we showed
the global picture of soil
moisture, and it's
hugely impactful.
Because again, for
the first time,
you have this global picture
of what things look like.
Unfortunately, one of the
things that was most striking
is how similar Saharan Africa
was to the Western United
States now in terms
of soil moisture.
But yeah, so it's is very
hard to pick top priorities.
I mean, I think we're sort
of moving down that road.
The global precipitation
measurement
has been huge in terms
of understanding.
That's one of the
biggest uncertainties
that we have now in climate
models is understanding
what climate change will
do to precipitation.
One of our big
focuses at NASA Ames
is better trying to understand
clouds and aerosols,
because they're, again,
one of the largest
uncertainties in our ability
to the forecast climate.
Because depending
on the type of cloud
and the location of the
cloud in the atmosphere,
it can either have a heating
effect or a cooling effect,
and so better understanding
that phenomenon.
In fact, we just got funded--
a little plug for us.
We just got funded for
a five year project
where we're going to base
actually the ER-2 aircraft out
of Western Africa.
And there's a phenomenon
there similar to the West
Coast of the United States where
you get a low strata stack,
but they have an awful
lot of biomass burning.
And so you get the smoke that
comes off of the continent.
It creates a bunch of the
aerosol that generates
cloud condensation nuclei.
And so it's a perfect
place on the planet for us
to try to better understand
how you distinguish
between these aerosol particles
and the clouds underneath them.
And so in that one,
you really need
those very detailed
measurements that you can only
get from an aircraft.
So I guess my wish list is
to change the NASA budget
by an order of magnitude.
How about that?
How do you get the data back to
farmers in an actionable way?
Well, so that's again
an excellent question.
And indeed, one of
really the strengths
of that project that we're
doing in the Central Valley
is that we're working with the
California Department of Water
Resources who has an
irrigation forecast system.
We're working with the
Western Growers Association.
We're working with a number of
growers, both large and small.
So some of the growers
have approached us
because they've
heard about the work.
So we just, about a
year ago, had Gallo come
and ask to be part
of this program.
And so we work very
much hand and glove
with the growers to see
what their needs are.
If you notice that one
little image I showed,
the ultimate is to have it on
a smartphone or a mobile device
because the farmers
typically aren't
sitting at their computers
back in their homes.
They're typically
out in the field,
trying to figure
out what's going on.
So we are definitely
working with them
to figure out what
best meets their needs.
Again, classic case,
though, of sort of NASA--
we're a research and
development agency.
We're not an operational agency.
So for us, when we demonstrate
these things, part of it
is just kind of figuring out
how to hand that technology off,
either to private companies
that will sell those services,
or other agencies like the
US Department of Agriculture
that can adopt some
of these capabilities.
And they have a whole
agricultural research service
where they could actually
adopt some of these things
and have it as one
of their capabilities
that they can share
with the farmers.
AUDIENCE: Do you release
your own measurements data
to the public?
Or do you think it
would make sense or not?
STEVE HIPSKIND: Aw,
a great question.
I'm glad you asked
because that was one
of the points I meant to make.
NASA and the United
States absolutely
sort of lead the world in the
fact that any data that we take
becomes publicly available
to everybody on the planet
when we take it.
And that's actually
pushing a number
of other space-faring countries
to change their data policies.
But yeah, that's one of
the beauties of what we do
is we make that data
publicly available.
And so we actually have a
data system that was set up
when we started on this program
of Earth Observation System,
EOS.
And indeed, we actually set up
a data distribution system back
before there was
a World Wide Web.
And so there's some
challenging-- I mean,
NASA has tried to keep up.
But I think what we're doing at
NASA Ames with the NASA Earth
Exchange and what you guys
are doing with Google Earth
Engine are exactly
the kind of things
that we need to be pushing
forward in that right now,
these data sets are in different
archives around the country.
And so the typical
thing is for scientists
to go download that data and
run it on their home computer.
And it was interesting in
that NEX and Google Earth
Engine had a very similar
heritage in that they
both recognize that compute
power has vastly improved.
Storage has become
easier and cheaper,
but bandwidth hasn't
really kept up.
So really, the idea is
bringing all that data
next to the analytics
and the models
so that people have
much more direct access
and so everybody's not trying
to move big, giant quantities
of data across the network.
But that's facilitated
by the fact
that all of this data that we
create is publicly available.
AUDIENCE: You showed the
pictures of the ozone hole
over Antarctica and
it didn't look--
even though the accord was made
a reasonably long time ago,
it didn't look like it was
closing significantly by 2000.
It wasn't growing,
I agree with you.
STEVE HIPSKIND: Well, I
don't remember, actually,
which years I showed.
That was probably--
AUDIENCE: 2011 was
the latest one.
STEVE HIPSKIND: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: 2011 was the latest.
STEVE HIPSKIND: Yeah.
Well, and so the
interesting thing about that
is one of the challenges with
that is that the CFCs-- I mean,
they were developed
in the 1930s to be
extremely stable molecules.
And so they have a very long
lifetime in the atmosphere.
And so we expected in
the late '80s, early '90s
when they were looking
at Montreal Protocol
that it would probably
be about mid-century
because these molecules
have about a 50 to 60
year lifetime in the atmosphere.
So it would probably
about mid-century.
So what we do see-- I mean,
we monitor this stuff.
And so what we do
see is that there's
been a tremendous reduction--
well, a reduction in the growth
rate, and actually, a reduction
in the total amount of chlorine
getting into the stratosphere.
But you know, it's got such
a long lag in the system
that we don't expect
the ozone hole
to completely come
back to pre-1980s
until some time around 2050.
So come back and talk
to me then and we'll
let you know if our
theories are right.
AUDIENCE: So I know you
said that you guys have
the largest Earth science
group doing research.
Is budget always a concern?
How do you guys lobby to get
more money or spread education
about earth science and stuff?
STEVE HIPSKIND: So
that's the beauty
of being a civil servant.
As NASA, we're an
executive agency.
So we actually work
for the president.
And so if we lobby,
we go to jail.
So we can only do outreach
and talk about the great work
we do, but we are explicitly
prohibited from lobbying.
But as you can imagine, it
is a very political thing.
And for those of us that are
very critically dependent--
so we work for the
president, but the Congress
sets our budget.
And if you follow
the Congress, you
know that there's
a certain party
in the country that's not that
interested in climate change.
And so they actually tried to
cut our budget by about $600
million this year.
Luckily, there's a lot of
political theater that goes on.
But when it comes down to
actually generating the budget,
I think saner heads prevail.
And so our budget looks like
it's going to be fairly stable.
So that's one of our
challenges, is just
trying to make sure that we have
some stability in the budget
because these missions
are fairly expensive.
And so when we get these
big radical shifts from year
to year, we have
quite a few people
that are working
on these missions,
and it's hard to start and stop.
And so for us, it's really
just a matter of recognizing--
I mean, you can only really
take the pulse of the planet
if you're making
the measurements.
And so the more that
we can get people
to appreciate the importance of
those continuous measurements,
the better.
But I mean, our opportunity
is to try to educate people
as much as possible.
And it's interesting
in that I think-- well,
and so our budget, so in
the last Decadal Survey
that the National Research
Council did, for example,
they gave us a wish
list of a program that
probably would have taken
at least twice the budget
that we have now.
And so we try to maintain
a stable executable program
but knowing that we can't
do everything that people
would like us to do.
And then you get
into conversations
about national priorities
and what's more important.
But I personally feel
that if we're really
going to try to make progress
in addressing climate change,
it can't be just the
federal government.
It's got to be all of us--
from individual actions,
but also corporate
actions, which
can be challenging because
of course, corporations
have different responsibilities
to, say, shareholders.
And so I mean, we've
entered into a number
of public/private partnerships.
But just getting
the conversation
going and speaking the same
language can be a challenge.
And so I think working toward
those goals is, in my view,
very important.
But I think part of it
is just getting people
to understand the
challenges that we face
and what it takes to
understand and address them.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, thank you.
STEVE HIPSKIND: OK, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]